uh this is basically going to be a tour
through all the steps on building and
productionizing uh retrieval augmented
generation systems right and so this is
using uh large language models to
basically build uh both basic uh to
Advanced applications over your data so
by way of introduction uh you know I'm
Jerry I'm co-founder CEO of llama index
uh llama index is a framework you know
at a very basic level it's a python
library right um to basic help you uh
connect your large language models with
your own sources of data to build
various types of applications uh so
let's get
started I think these days um in the
world of generative AI obviously it's um
exploded unpopularity around this time
last year actually uh and within the
past year there's been a lot of interest
especially among Enterprises in building
um different types of use cases on top
of waterf fils some of the most popular
ones we're seeing include document
processing and extraction so being able
to extract structured outputs from un
unstructured documents knowledge search
and question answering so that part is
pretty quar to this idea of rag or
retrieval augmented generation uh
conversational agents or chat Bots
basically a chat GPT like experience but
over maybe a data source uh as well as
workflow automation so you know given um
some sort of flow like can you actually
get a large language model to just
execute it instead of you having the
human in the loop
so the overall context maybe just taking
a step back is that um you know large
language models are a phenomenal piece
of technology for knowledge generation
and reasoning you open up chat gbt in a
browser you can ask at basically a lot
of different things and it'll give you
back an answer right well you can ask it
to debug like python code you can ask it
uh articles about or basically anything
on Wikipedia you can ask it to generate
like a poem for you in the style of you
know a famous poet uh but it's pre-train
on large amounts of publicly available
data um but as people are using trat gbt
or a similar experiences uh you're
finding that um there's a few different
use cases that are emerging like
question answering text generation
summarization and planning and pretty
much ever since the start of last year
people start asking themselves the
question you know how do you actually
augment language models with our own
private sources of data this includes
anything from Ross or raw files like
PDFs on your hard drive to like common
services that you use like notion slack
uh to databases uh including both uh SQL
databases like traditional data stores
uh as well as kind of like the newer age
of vector databases as
well and so given all this data right
whether I'm a developer or organization
how do we best uh augment mods with
it a few paradigms for inserting
knowledge uh have have emerged um one
one idea is retrieval augmentation where
you actually fix the model um and then
you put the context into the prompt uh
so in this setting basically and this is
a setting we'll probably focus on you
have the language model uh you know open
AI GPT 4 Turbo and we don't actually
train at edart we have our own sources
of knowledge let's say a bunch of notion
essays and we figure out how to actually
take all this context from ocean essays
and put it into the input prompt right
and and you know maybe you have like
gigabytes of data or just a lot of text
Data within your your Text corpus but
you need to figure out how do you
actually figure out how to retrieve the
most relevant pieces of text to put it
into the in promp and we'll go over this
in just a bit the other Paradigm of
course is fine tuning we'll touch on it
briefly uh within this slide as well or
within this talk but it's basically you
know you want to actually train the
model itself update some portion of the
model weights to try tocor incorporate
new
knowledge the way I think about llama
index is it's a data framework for LM
applications um it basically helps you
uh you know it gives you the tools
across the life cycle of actually
connecting your data with LMS this
includes three main components starting
from your data sources we first want to
injust the data uh we mostly do this
through our community-driven site called
llah Hub which has uh over 150 Plus data
loaders uh we have a variety of
different other Integrations on there
too um but basically this is a starting
point to allow you to load in different
data sources the second piece is
transforming processing them into a
storage system um so how do you store
and index your data for different types
of use cases um and this in these
indices this data storage uh you know
this is where L index got the name from
is specifically designed to actually
feed into the langage mod and of course
number three is then how do you actually
retrieve in query over this data uh and
use it in conjunction with your language
model of choice uh and this includes the
variety of use cases I talked about like
question answering summarization agents
and
more um we'll actually go through this
and and um adjust a bit uh but basically
to basically set up some sort of
question answering it's very simple um
you load in some data uh Second Step is
you index stuff right like you index a
set of documents um third is you can
start asking questions over it uh so in
around 5 of code without really needing
to know what's going on under the hood
you can basically get some sort of
question answering like system over your
data first let's talk about kind of this
idea of retrieval augmented generation
uh and how it works so we'll go over the
rag
stack the current rag stack for building
a question answering system uh mainly
consists of two main components one is
data injection and parsing uh and the
second step is data query so in data
injection and parsing uh you start off
with some Source documents and then what
you want to do is you want to chunk up
these documents uh into a bunch of
slices and then you embed each slice and
put them into for instance a vector
database and then once the data is in a
vector database and embedded then you do
retrieval and synthesis right so to go
over this in more detail uh in the data
injection and forcing stage we want to
take in some documents and split up the
documents into roughly like you know
even Trunks and there's different types
of parsing strategies for this each
trunk is just like a slice of raw text
from the original document you generate
an embedding for each trunk like open AI
embeddings sentence Transformers and
then you put your trunk into a vector
database in the second part um you uh
you know once the data is actually in
the vector database then you want to do
retrieval and synthesis you first want
to find the topk most similar chunks
from the vector database collection and
then you plug these trunks into the LM
response synthis
module now let's talk a little bit about
how this response synthesis module works
right because in this stage right here
you're feeding in all these text trunks
into the context window of the
LM and then some natural questions arise
like okay but what if you know the
context window actually overflows what
what if I actually have you know 5,000
tokens of retrieve context uh but the
context window itself actually only
handles you know like 4,000 at most so
um because like without that otherwise
you would just like stuff this into the
prop right you just like literally put
it into the giant text string and then
call the llm and that's pretty trivial
to do so there's kind of two strategies
have uh emerged and there there's more
to but there's different types of like
response synthesis strategies to
basically summarize or over larger
amounts of context that overflow the
context window uh one basic Strate is
this idea of like create and refine
where you you know take each chunk uh
like pack as much as you can into each
context window and then uh consider them
as like nodes so for node one um you
first synthesize an answer over node one
right this is the initial chunk of text
that can actually fit in the context
window uh given the query you get back
an initial response and then you feed
this response along with node two and
every subsequent node um and the query
in like back into the LM right to
continue generating a response so it's
like you first generate a response from
node one and then you continue refining
it um as you go on through the subsquent
nodes until you get back a final
response another idea is this idea of
like hierarchical summarization uh we
call it tree summarization and llama
index but basically you know assuming
you have a bunch of nodes which both all
fit into the context vendom you could
hierarchy generate answers um until you
get back a final answer at the end this
strategy uh tends to lead to slightly
more cored uh text Generations just
because you're kind of uh continuously
re sumarize things uh but at the same
time this can also be pretty paralyzable
because you can run all these in
parallel in parallel LM
calls so with that said you know this is
what the basic rag stack looks like and
we'll go over this in you know this is
basically the quick start tutorial of
llama index but we'll just Vis show you
how this
works um you know first we want to pip
install LOM index so this is a python
package it's available on piie uh and so
definitely encourage all of you to track
it
out um for the purposes of this notebook
I probably just won't be running the
cells uh itself but I'll I'll just walk
through the steps and show you how it
works so one of the first things you do
is you know from LOM index import all
the necessary components uh I'll go over
the this and and what they mean in just
bit but we'll load our data source
that's step one um and in this case
we're going to uh download Paul grams
essay right um this is one of his
popular essays the title is what I
worked on it was released in February
2021 and we load it in through one of
our simple utility functions like the
simple directory reader which will load
in a text file uh here we just uh have
the file setting in our drawbox in plain
text but this is the full say right um
it's just a big text
file uh it's not the biggest actually
you know it's it's like 10,000 something
tokens um and you know there's
definitely bigger data sources but at
the same time you know you can kind of
get a sense of how this
works and so assuming a 4,000 token
window limit uh this would definitely an
OP nowadays given the token Windows
have increased 100K uh we kind of need a
bigger example um but you know for the
purpose of demonstration this is this is
how it
works the Second Step here is we're
going to call index equals Vector sort
indexa from documents this is
essentially the the ingestion and
indexing piece of that that rag stack
that I mentioned so uh and and here we
hide a lot of it under the hood but
within LOM index we have the
abstractions to basically allow you to
compose your own injection pipeline if
needed right this this is just like the
blackbox method if you don't want to
actually do that under the hood and so
by doing this what you'll do is chunking
and embedding and indexing you'll take
in these documents or this one document
split it up embed each chunk and
actually put it into the the storage
system the next step is now you want to
get back a query engine right over this
index now that data is indexed you can
now you know run some sort of query over
that index and here you see the response
um you know query engine. query what did
the author do growing up you get back
some
response and this is a this is the
generator response like and and this
well this follows that second step of or
or the the query part of that rag stack
right where you do retrieval um with a
top k equals 2 and then put it into the
context window the LM and you get back
this answer uh the author me mentioned
that before College you know they wrote
short stories write wrote programs on
the IBM
1401 and so not only can you get back
the responsing and also print the source
nodes um and one of the main
requirements for basically building J
applications is that you have proper uh
accountability and transparency and
sourcing right so that you actually kind
of understand what's going on in this
step uh we show that this is the
specific chunk that's actually been
retrieved uh to help you answer the
question
okay now um jumping
back that was a quick overview of of how
the basic rag stack worked and so now
let's talk about some challenges with it
right so in what cases uh does this
actually fail um and if you've set this
up yourself over the past year you know
using a framework plus an LM plus Vector
store chances are you might have
identified failure cases yourself as
well the way I think about challenges
with naive rag um is there's different
types of failure modes there's stuff
that is quality related like you're
actually just not getting back the right
responses given uh the questions that
you're asking and there's also
non-quality related stuff too like
latency cost uh and and
sinking so in terms of response quality
um there's a few different properties of
of uh of bad responses the first is bad
reproval um and and there's a few
aspects of that reproval this means that
given a question you're not actually
returning the relevant chunks and if of
course if you're not returning the
relevant chunks you're not going to get
back a good generator response right and
a lot of times this retrieval process is
completely independent of the capability
of the LM itself the LM can be very very
good but if you don't get back the right
answer you're not going to synthesize
the right response so a few different
properties here uh one is low Precision
not all the chunks in the retrieve set
are relevant um and so this means that
you might have a lot of noise in the
retriev context you might get back a lot
of fluff um and the issue is that if you
get back a lot of fluff depending on the
llm you're using um some llms are better
than others at identifying you know the
relevant information within a mess of
text and some are pretty bad at it and
so what you what this can run into is
the LM can end up hallucinating right
give you some answer that's unrelated to
your question um because of all the the
noisy context there's also loss in the
middle problems which are a common
problem like the point identified with a
variety of different LMS where if the
relevant context is somewhere in the
middle of a context the LM tends to have
trouble finding it right and you can
look at analysis this supplies the LMS
with large context Windows to like open
AI anthropic all these like the 128k
200k context Windows if you actually
stretch it to that amount um you'll find
that a lot of information starts getting
lost in the middle right so this is the
issue of returning too much context when
you actually um um you know try to set
up these systems so so more context is
not always
better the other aspect is low recall
not all the relevant chunks are actually
retrieved um and here is where you know
given your retrieval algorithm maybe
it's topk embedding lookup you're not
actually getting enough context for the
LM to synthesize an
answer the next aspect here is bad
response generation um and so even if
you get back for instance the relevant
results and of course like some of this
is a function of low Precision low
recall um you might actually end up with
some LM failures and a lot of this is
due to the model itself um you might get
hallucination issues the model might
make up an answer that's not actually in
the context um you might get irrelevance
uh the model sometimes comes up with an
answer that doesn't actually answer your
question um and of course like you know
depending on some cases the model might
make up an answer that doesn't actually
uh you know it could be harmful
offensive or it just generally doesn't
actually adhere to guidelines that you
set right and that's probably the more
General problem you you prompted it to
Output things in a certain style or even
have like structured outputs and it just
didn't
listen so given these failures um we
have to think about the type of software
system that we're building um as well as
like levers and knobs that we can tune
to try to actually improve these system
what's very interesting here is that if
you've ever done machine learning before
this part is pretty similar to machine
learning right um just the
hyperparameters of a machine learning
model um when you build an LM Software
System you have the LM right here and
you're basically wrapping it with a
bunch of different chunks uh different
pieces different modules um that
combined kind of create this higher
level blackbox system um you have you
know your your documents your chunking
retrieval strategy uh you know your your
embedding model and of course the LM um
and and and and like stuff like the
prompt template as well all these are
parameters that affect the performance
of your final result given any sort of
input question and so unlike traditional
software systems you can't really reason
about stuff in isolation because all
these are parameters that affect the
Final End performance and they're kind
of stochastic black
boxes and so to categorize like the set
of parameters you can actually tune
there's data like can we store
additional information Beyond raw text
chunks there's embeddings can we
optimize our embedding representations
there is retrieval can we do better than
topk Ting lookup uh and there's the
synthesis piece there's the prompts used
for the LM um as well as like can you
actually use the LM kind of more along
the retrieval piece or even have more
agentic
strategies of course before you try out
any of these things and very similar to
traditional machine learning is the fact
that you need some sort of evaluation
data set the main difference with
traditional machine learning is that you
don't need a training data set because
you're not actually training the model
and so typically when you use like you
know SK learn or or like pytorch or
whatever uh you you typically set up
both a training and eval set beforehand
um because you know you have a data set
and you do some split and then you you
allocate 70% to training 30% to evals
the main thing with llms is that you
don't really need a training data set to
get started at all you do need an eval
data set and so basically in in like the
Mind space of a developer they need to
allocate some time to basically uh think
about you know I need to allocate some
time to gather an evaluation data set to
actually try to try to evaluate measure
the
performance so in terms of um evaluation
uh let's talk about it because because
you know how do we actually evaluate a
rag system um and how to to what extent
is this challenging and and how is it
different than for instance evaluating a
traditional NL system so um a rag system
uh for you know to simplify a little bit
has two main components there's one the
retrieval piece and the synthesis piece
right you can have more complex systems
too but this is the thing we start with
you can evaluate an isolation so you can
evaluate retrieval and isolation you can
also evaluate synthesis and isolation
you can also evaluate this entire system
uh end to
endend there's an open question of
whether you should start with N2 an
evaluation or evaluation isolation um I
think I've wavered back and forth on
this uh right now my current leaning is
you know maybe you should just evaluate
n to end first just to just validate
some like 50 data points 30 to 50 data
points whether or not your system is
generally working right and then based
on the whether it's not working you can
go in and try to actually isolate like
the source of the failure whether it's
retrieval or the
prompt but in terms of like how do we
think about retrieval evaluation right
um what is retrieval again given a query
and given the retriever you get back a
set of retrieved IDs um basically this
corresponds to the text chunks and the
high level goal of retrieval should be
that given the query you return the most
relevant chunks and so if you actually
have ground truth of what those relevant
trunks are supposed to be you can
evaluate the predicted rankings of these
trunks against the actual trunks uh
using some sort of ranking or the the
ground truth trunks using some sort of
ranking metrics right so if for instance
these are the expected IDs you can
compare the predicted against the ground
truth using uh you know traditional
ranking metrics like success rate Mr um
uh they should say ndcg um but a variety
of these things and and this is not
really anything new um this is something
that's existed before maybe one thing to
consider though is that ranking metrics
and and retrieval um like the quality of
your retrieve results don't necessarily
completely correlate with generation
performance uh even if things are in the
correct ranked order because of the way
that LMS actually attend to this context
where they forget things in the middle
um it's not actually guaranteed that
this is the best ordering to give to the
LM if that makes sense um sometime and
and that's something that we haven't
fully explored yet but it's just some
intuition to be aware
of um evaluation end to endend so here
is you know given a user query and given
the entire rag pipeline um try to EV and
given the generator response along with
some context try to evaluate how good
the generator response is Right
according to a variety of different
factors if you have have the ground
truth answer you can evaluate for
instance correctness uh whether or not
how much the predicted answer matches
the ground truth answer without the
ground trth answer uh you can evaluate
stuff like how much the response matches
the context how much the response
matches the query all these are just
pieces of text which means that you need
some way of actually measuring how good
this piece of text is in comparison to
another piece of text um and so you can
use traditionalistic uh for this kind of
numeric metrics uh the I think these
days there's a lot of folks that are
very interested in LM based EVS uh and
there's some papers where you know like
gp4 can be a relatively reliable human
judge and as these models get better
they'll probably get better at being
able to judge things um and so a lot of
these metrics are dependent on actually
calling an LM under the
hood a little bit more about this like
gb4 is a good human grader um I think
this is a a good article from data
Brooks a few months ago but basically
you know like if if you take a look at
can human versus gbt grading assignments
uh for some of these um uh for for like
scoring like how good gbt 3.5 is uh
there there's like a decent um
correlation there right um and so if we
apply gb4 for instance as an llm eval
grader we can ask it to do a few
different tasks uh some examples are
correctness like whether the response
matches a golden answer so you can just
prompt jb4 G these two examples how much
one matches the other you can prompt it
for faithfulness so why the other
response actually matches the retrieve
context this will test for
hallucinations mostly right so given
some context if it doesn't match this
means that it's roughly hallucinating uh
relevancy whether the response actually
matches the question so whether it
actually gives an answer and of course
like guidelines whether it matches
guidelines
great so we talked about basic
um we talked about how to do evaluations
U because that gives you the basis from
which you can experiment with some more
Advanced Techniques and now let's talk
about optimizing rag systems right and
so we'll we'll go into this section you
know talk about some basic lever you can
p and then we'll talk about the
extensions here like we'll talk about
General um um ways to kind of extend
beyond this and this includes fine
tuning and
agents um there's a variety of things
you can do um and and these are all
practices that have emerged over the
past year in terms of trying to optimize
your system for better performance uh
you know you have this question
answering bot set up the five lines of
code and L index here are a lot of
things that you can try um on the left
side of the axis you see things that are
easier to implement typically have lower
latency and cost and these are kind of
just like TBL Stak things you can try so
you're not going to make like step
changes in the performance or
capabilities but hopefully you can like
tune some parameters that make it work
better on the right side of the axis
like this is stuff that is more
expressive like some of these things
will actually lead to big step changes
in the capability of your entire
Pipeline and answering more advanced
questions but they typically are are
harder to implement um and a lot of
times especially the AG gentic stuff as
well as fine tuning they incur higher
Lane costs like fine tuning is a onetime
fixed cost AG gentic stuff tends to
incur High laty um at at query
time
so let's first walk through some table
stake stuff right in terms of things
that just levers or parameters you can
tune to actually improve performance the
first is trunk sizes tun your trunk size
can have outsize impacts on performance
um and and so for like uh if your your
trunk size is too small let's say your
trunk size is like 100 tokens which is
like 80 words or so um and your top K is
equal to two that's not a lot of context
for your LM to actually work off of so
if you do retrieval you retrieve 160
tokens in context and the LM just
doesn't have that much information to
answer a question it tends to not give
you very good answers on the other hand
if your chunk sizes are too big one it's
going to cost you more money and and be
slower but two is again going back into
the loss in the middle problems like
this might actually end up confusing the
alet because the relevant context is
somewhere in the mess of retrieve trunks
so it's not obvious that more retriev
tokens um actually equates to to higher
performance right and and so um
typically there's some sort of like
U-shaped curve in in basically error
rate versus like trunk size and the the
the optimal um trunk size is somewhere
in the middle right there's not
necessarily a good Universal trunk size
for everything because it really depends
on your use case I think for basic
question answering tasks our defaults
are around a thousand um and and that
tends to work pretty well with a top k
equals 2 but of course you should tune
that
another basic like table Stakes thing is
prompt tionary um I think we've tried
pretty hard to make sure that basically
all these prompts that are used uh
within our rag pipeline are exposed to
the user we also have Integrations with
observability providers like for
instance like a rise Phoenix weights and
biases open
lemetry and these um allow you to trace
uh all prompts and LM calls going in
through the entire system along with
other stuff like ret calls as well and
so it's I I highly encourage all of you
if you're building these pipelines to
try to use some of these uh tools and
and a lot of these you know you can
integrate with L index in literally one
line of code um to give you more
visibility to what's going on under the
hood so uh for instance uh and we talked
about response synthesis at the
beginning portion of these slides um the
the prom template typically looks
something like this like context
information from sources listed below
you have some context and given this
information try to answer the question
and then here's the question there's
ways you can customize this promp
template right um You can try making it
um you know add some special tokens or
model dependent um this this product is
typically optimized for like open AI um
tends to work less well maybe on other
models and sometimes you have like
special formats or like instruction
brackets that you need to add to the
prompt right to basically because it's
it's been pre-trained on on that type of
data um so for instance like llama 2 uh
anthropic a lot of these require like
custom brackets um another way is you
can add like few shot examples H for
instance if you're trying to get
structured outputs like if you're lit if
you're trying to get the model to output
something in a Json format or you're
trying to get it to Output stuff in a
certain style uh adding both positive
and negative examples to The Prompt
itself tends to help the model and
really understanding whether or not um
uh you know whether or not the output
format is correct
um and and so it it helps to enforce
more reliable
outputs um other ways of customization
um include you know there there's a
paper that came out like a few weeks ago
till like a month ago where you can um
try to add like emotions to The Prompt
um and it's it's a pretty funny paper
because basically it turns out that if
you uh like um really try to you know
appeal to make the LM feel bad basically
um it tensively to higher performance
but you know you can try that out at
your own
risk um the model itself the LM of
course is uh quite an important step
towards being able to um uh have a
perform right pipeline what we did
within laama index is we integrate with
like 20 plus llms right like we
integrate with all the open source
models as well as all the paid popular
paid models um and we ran some basic
benchworks uh to to understand um what
their capabilities are on easy to hard
tasks uh so if you look at and and this
might be a little small but if you look
at the columns here for instance um here
the columns are easy tasks to to harder
tasks like data agents uh and and on the
rows you see the model name these tasks
include like the basic rag pipelines um
to the router query engine um to the to
what we call a sub question query engine
based some basic planning capabilities
to text a SQL um structured output
extraction as well as agents and here
like check marks show whether or not
this model is actually capable of doing
this over a pretty simple data set this
is just like the Lama to paper um and
and red means that it doesn't actually
give you the right results and then the
warning sign means it's kind of uh
inconsistent so the task performance on
ye hard tasks varies wildly among
different LMS um currently one of the
best models that we've seen is Zephyr um
and and of course mistol um and these on
the open source uh side are s billion
parameter models that actually exhibit
decent properties in terms of some
aspects like structured output
extraction Texas SQL as well as agentic
behavior um the L the paid llm apis
typically will will will do better in
terms of performance across the board um
like GT4 of course like does well in
pretty much everything um gbt 3.5 tends
to do okay on on tasks but is a little
worse on gentic stuff and of course
there's like the cloud models from
anthropic
too there's also of course um being able
to customize your embedding model um and
we've since updated these numbers and
this is on a very toy data set so so
definitely don't um kind of take these
um numbers as is uh definitely run it
over the data that you have but the
embedding model and the rewriting
quality significantly affects how good
your rral is and so different models
like open AI uh Ada tends to be one of
the leaders in actually giving uh good
results um there is of course Gina
Voyage coher V3 all these have which
have become competitive with or even
surpass the capabilities of uh the Ada
model for open Ai and so you should
definitely try out different models see
what makes sense for you in terms of
cost and latency um but uh some of these
models will do better than others and
actually giving you back relevant
context from your
taex another example of something that's
pretty table Stakes is metadata
filtering right so metadata filtering is
um uh or or maybe to take a step back um
metadata is context that you can
interject into each text TR um so if you
imagine just a block of text uh metadata
could just be like a Json dictionary
that you append on top of the text um
some examples this includes uh very
simple types of data as well as more
complex types as includes stuff like
page number document title a summary of
adjacent trunks questions that the trunk
can answer um some benefits of this Um
this can help retrieval so if you
actually inject the metadata into the
text a lot of times that actually gives
you back the relevant answers uh or or
the relevant trunks uh this can help
augment response quality by having the
metadata in the text itself uh you can
actually uh give the LM more information
from which you can do stuff like s
sources um uh you know a like augment
the response with more context and
having this metadata also integrates
with uh met structured filter
capabilities within Vector
databases so one General thing to think
about as metadata is most of the world
runs on semi-structured data um and and
so even if you have you know a bunch of
raw text chunks chances are there's
going to be structured information that
you can and probably should attend to
your data and you can basically within
law index have control over whether this
is used during the retrieval or
synthesis step or use as part of of a
metadata
filter an example here is um let's say
you have a bunch of financial documents
um they're all stored in a vector
database uh and then let's say you just
running like topk retrieval using raw
semantic search from the vector database
um you ask a question can you tell me
the risk factors in 2021 raw semantic
search is low precision right and so
given a query string um you are going to
ask this entire collection of 10K
document Trunks and they're literally
just raw chunks of text and let's say
you get the top four most relevant um
chunks given this question there's just
no guarantee you're actually going to
get back the relevant document Trunks
from 2021 you might get back stuff from
2020 2019 you know um and and what we
found is typically um if you just run
pure rantic search for these types of
questions you're not really getting back
uh a lot of relevant information and the
sends up confusing the
btel an idea here is okay but what if
you know given this type of question and
the fact that these Vector databases
actually support metadata filtering and
and by the way what is metadata
filtering this just means that you know
given some sort of query um to a vector
database you can also specify a set of
filters and what it's basically a wear
clause in a SQL statement and you'll
first filter by these filters these
metadata filters and then R run semantic
search given the query within the filter
data so it really kind of uh makes your
retrieve set more precise because all
the stuff that's outside the set is just
irrelevant so given a question like this
if you can actually infer the metadata
filters like given this question infer
that you know we want to filter year
equals 2021 then you can remove the
relevant candidates in in the first pass
and this will actually increase the
Precision of the recre contexts right to
basically guarantee that you have the
relevant
results a general concept here um and
and we we'll kind of do two slides in
advanced retrieval um and so this is
moving a little bit beyond um table
stakes and a little bit more towards uh
kind of thinking about stuff um uh that
that's a little bit more
involved one of these Concepts is small
to big reval um one of the intuitions
about this whole process about taking in
a document and splitting it up into a
bunch of trunks is that embedding uh
stuff like embedding just trunks
themselves feels pretty suboptimal you
have like delineated the boundaries of
these trunks beforehand right and this
these trunks are just these are
typically very arbitrary you're
splitting on sentences you're splitting
on paragraphs and sometimes context
might actually carry a carry over
between different chunks and you're kind
of cutting it straight down the
middle so a lot of times what actually
helps here is what we call kind of like
um small to big retrieval where you
first actually embed the text at the
sentence level um and then you retrieve
text at the sentence level so when you
get given a question return the most
relevant sentences given your question
but before you actually feed this to the
LM you EXP that window during LM
synthesis so you have an expanded window
of text around the central piece of
relevant context to actually feed to the
LM context right and why is this in
interesting it's decoupling basically um
the chunk that you have for retrieval
versus the chunk that you use for
synthesis and the original assumption
was that they're one and the same trunks
but here you're actually retrieving a
smaller chunk and feeding a bigger chunk
into the alen synthesis piece we found
that this idea actually leads to
generally better performance um here is
just a very qualitative example uh and
of course you can run this on your own
data set as well um we've run this
across a variety of just very basic data
sets and typically have found better
better performance by doing this uh here
in this example with sentence window
retrieval of top k equals 2 you get back
a proper answer with naive retrieval um
because you're just returning kind of
these these arbitrary tax trunks with k
equals 2 and even k equals 5 you're not
actually able to get back
answer
um and and so this is just more of a
visual diagram showcasing how this works
um but if you take a look at for
instance like this piece right here um
the way it works is you can think about
like a smaller chunk as a reference uh
like a pointer to a bigger chunk right
so you index where Tre the references
but then the actual thing you feed to
the LM is the thing that's like d
reference or or the bigger Chun
um and and and here is just maybe one
General comment on an example like
Advanced retrieval architecture that you
could build right um and this draws
lessons from existing retrieval best
practices as well as um uh kind of the
of course like the like the rag stack
itself in the past year um this general
idea is like the rag Fusion retriever uh
which combines best practices around
retrieval uh with of course the Alum at
the end to generate a final answer um
and the interesting thing here is seeing
how you take some of these like
traditional retrieval practices and
actually have at the llm as certain
steps here to actually help augment the
capabilities of the entire pipeline if
we think about generally what are good
practices around retrieval the first is
given a user query actually try to
translate or rewrite that query into
either subqueries like decompose it into
a bunch of sub problems um or actually
you know given your knowledge about the
context translate it into something
that's that's more amendable for a
retrieval right and so given this
question um uh you can actually do this
query generation using an LM to to to
right to to generate these subqueries uh
before you could use like traditional
models characteristics of rewrite these
queries here you can actually just
prompt an llm um and this is one step
and and you generate a set of parallel
queries now for each query um one idea
here is this idea of like Ensemble
retrieval actually um and and this is
something that's kind of Avail been been
around in traditional retrieval settings
too but assuming you have a bunch of
different types of retriever uh
retrieval modes like some you might have
like something that does semantic search
you might have something that does like
hybrid or keyword search you might have
something with like a different top case
or or maybe even like a different neural
net architecture and or or a different
embedding model you run this query in
parallel across every Retriever and get
back a set of retrieve results uh for
every node or for for every retriever
right so let's say the top three from
every
retriever the third step is this idea of
fusion uh reranking um pretty much every
production grade retrieval system out
there uses some form of ranking or
reranking after the initial pass um and
this is what we call fusion and there's
some different algorithms that you can
use to actually try to fuse uh you know
the original set retrieve into the new
set um but the idea here is you know you
have some input set of canidate set of
retrieve contexts it could be very big
you know the top K could be very wide
like uh in the tens or hundreds even and
you run some sort of rewriting Al
algorithm on top of that to both filter
down the set as well as reorder the
context or or um the priority of each
node and finally given the filtered
reite set of nodes you actually
synthesize and get back a response this
is a pretty good reference architecture
around Advanced retrieval um of course
like you know given what everything that
I just said it like every use case is a
little bit custom um but if for instance
you're interested in diving into just
you know a general architecture around
better retrieval this is something I
would encourage you to look at right um
these are just some best practices you
can combine it with the llm and this
will probably give you better results
than um just doing the topk um and of
course like this might actually be a
little slower though because you're
involving more steps in this process and
it will probably cost more money are
something to be aware
of in the last probably uh like quarter
of of these slides um we'll talk about
kind of some of these more advanced
concepts um and specifically we'll talk
about both agents uh as well as
fine-tuning so I think a lot of uh folks
might have heard about agents in the
past year um there's been a lot of
agentic projects that have also emerged
Ed um and and it might be good to maybe
understand first what exactly is an
agent and the second piece is how do we
actually think about agents in the
context of um you know how it relates to
what we just talked about which is like
rag um the way we think about agents is
they're basically L empowered knowledge
workers that can not only read
information about the world but they can
also do rights right they can modify
State um they can perform actions and so
a workflow of an agent might look like
the following you might first have an
action to read the latest emails for
instance from your Gmail inbox you might
have another action to retrieve contexts
for instance from your knowledge base um
and this itself uh could be a rag
pipeline so an agent could just be an
outer layer that like calls the rag
pipeline as a
tool it could analyze a file right
either with a rag pipeline or with like
a code interpreter depending on the file
itself and the final set step is it
could you given all this information uh
send an update um and and this is
something that actually mutates State
this could send a message on slack um
implicit in this entire thing is that
there's some sort of like uh sequential
decision making meaning that a data
agent is actually stateful right between
actions so that it can remember what's
going going on in between actions and
use uh and store that in the state and
use that to inform the next action that
can actually take
um the way we think about what we call
data agents right and and we call them
data agents because we're mostly excited
about agents in the context of kind of
knowledge automation is there's some
core components um there's the agent
reasoning Loop um which can contain um
you know this is basically the outer
loop that will reason over what tools to
use and there's the tools
themselves the tools themselves can
include API
calls to different services so you could
for instance reason over how to send a
message to like slack API um or you
could reason about how to do a query
something as a tool like search Google
Bing Wikipedia or query or rag pipeline
um and of course like a one component
here is the the conversation history not
mentioned here but in the diagram being
able to Source State over time right and
so on every action um you actually want
to fetch stuff from your conversation
history or memory in some way to help
you inform what's the next action you're
going to
take um the agent reasoning Loop itself
there's a variety of papers that have
come out in the past year as well as the
year before uh as well as techniques and
things that are a little bit more
abstracted away so for instance like uh
if you just you depend on open AI for
instance open AI has now an assistance
API that will handle this Loop execution
for you uh they actually just hide the
logic under the hood uh and with if
you're just using another function
calling API you can actually just do a
while loop over over function calling
right um and the react agent is uh
compatible generally with any LM this is
a paper that came out last year and this
way of prompting llms to basically kind
of decompose um uh like a complex
question into sub questions do Chain of
Thought and Inter leave reasoning with
tool
use the tools themselves again can
include query engine tools like rag
pipeline so you can actually just query
you know existing pipeline as a tool
um they we also have a variety of
different tools on llama Hub we have
like 20 or 30 different tools now from a
code interpreter slack notion and these
are all tools you can plug in as part of
an agent the way we think about any tool
is it's just a python class that you
feed to an agent uh with a variety of
different functions and so it's very
pythonic um but um the the way the agent
thinks about it is it basically treats
it as API interface it has knowledge of
the doc string the arguments and the all
can actually given the doc arguments
infer what's the right parameters to
call each tool right given that's going
to call the
tool so um maybe jumping ahead just
really quick um how do you actually
research and retrieve data from a
knowledge base with agents um and and
this touches on using query engines as
tools as part of an overall agent um
there's different types of query engin
that LL index offers um and and these
include rag traditional rag pipeline
setup like semantic search and
summarization uh advanced stuff like
document comparisons but also kind of
other kind of interesting tools as well
for instance we have for instance a
Texas SQL tool or we have another one
that allows you to actually uh combine
uh structured data with unstructured
data all these are essentially data
tools uh some of them qualify more as
rag than others in the end doesn't
really matter um and if you plug these
tools in as part of an agent Loop then
the agent can reason about which tools
you use given a task uh to actually try
to answer the question right so the way
we think about honestly how rag extends
to the agent setting is the agents is
basically just an outer reasoning layer
on top of the tool itself uh that can
basically take in more complex questions
and do stuff like train of thought to
actually answer uh the
question an example for this um is
financial analysis with like agents plus
plus rag uh so given a question like you
know compare and contrast Uber and lifts
Revenue growth right again looking at
like the SEC 10K filings for both Uber
and lft um this is another example where
uh if you just feed this to a regular
rag pipeline you'll likely not get back
the right results uh so compare and
contrast Uber and lifts Revenue growth
you try to get for instance like the top
four most relevant pieces of context
you're not going to get back the right
results um the agent will try to or or
like the rag pipeline will give you back
some random contacts maybe all Uber all
lift um and you might not be able to
answer the question question on the
other hand if you feed this to an agent
um the agent will actually break this
down break this question into sub
questions over uh tools right and it'll
first break this down into sub questions
break it into easier questions like you
know what was Uber's Revenue growth in
2020 well lifts growth in 2021 each one
might query a rag pipeline itself right
and and that each each sub question will
be more easily answerable via VIA rag
pipeline and then finally once you uh
get back these answers to these sub
questions then you combine these answers
at the end to get back The Final
Answer um some general things to think
about if you're building agents
especially if you're building them in
the context or rag is uh sometimes these
tools or API services will give you back
a lot of results um some of these like
for instance if you query like a
Wikipedia page or even Google search and
you try to load the entire contents some
a web page you're going to get back a
lot of context if you're working with
limited context Windows a lot of times
this will just overflow the context
window and probably confuse uh the LM so
one strategy here is if your tools
inherently return a lot of data try to
figure out a way for them to one not
return a lot of data and some some basic
concepts that we offer include being
able to Index this data on the flight um
so for instance like given a lot of data
um put it into some sort of vector DB
first and then um have the agent
actually take a separate action to query
this on demand Vector
DB another General principle and best
practice if you're designing agents is
to be able to handle a large like figure
out a best a good way to handle a large
number of tools agents even gb4 based
agents like the most powerful type
available tend to start failing once the
number of tools goes beyond five or six
um and so if you have like hundreds or
even thousands of candidate tools I
would think about how to build an index
over the these tools and then do some
sort of tool retrieval retrieve the most
relevant ones to actually pass to your
agent right so if you have 100 tools try
to First during query time filter it out
for the most relevant tools first you
know a candidate set of like 10 tools
and then have the agent pick out of that
candidate set of T tools like which ones
to use given the user
query skipping back really quick um an
example architecture that we've done is
this idea of a multi-document agent
architecture um and this combines a few
different advanced concepts actually we
have both agents but actually
hierarchical agents where we have like
sub agents as part of tools to other
agents and we did this because we wanted
to explore Advanced architectures to
help answer tackle questions where
there's certain questions that like
standard topk rag can't answer and the
solution here to build is just
multi-document agents right um like
there's certain questions like um like
being able to you know get a summary
over any subset of documents being able
to do proper document comparisons
between different documents um being
able to for instance do some sort of
structured quering over the set of
documents uh and then and then like
combining that with these this
unstructured data um and this
architecture can basically handle these
Advanced queries by actually in some
sort of structured manner take given a
query break it down into a bunch of sub
questions over these documents decide
whether to do sech or summarization and
get get back the final
answer and probably the the last section
um I'll talk a little bit about fine
tuning
right so so far we've mostly focused on
retrieval augmentation um retrieval
augmentation in the sense that you know
given the model itself we don't train
the model uh anymore we just fix the
model uh and then we just you know set
up the right software tooling and
abstractions and of course an evaluation
data set um to actually try to create a
performant functioning system and so in
the last bit I'll talk about fine
tuning where what is the relationship
between fine-tuning and rag right like
um how what parts can we actually
fine-tune to try to optimize
performance you can basically fine-tune
um a system in two ways you can
fine-tune the embeddings um you can also
fine-tune the outlines you can also
fine-tune additional stuff like the reer
um as well as like you know maybe even
the retrieval algorith itself depending
on what you use right but just for basic
purposes we can say we can find to the
embeddings and also finding the LMS so
the LMS or sorry the the embeddings are
a key part um of this overall system
right they affect the quality of your
retrieved results they're important for
encoding the semantic context every your
knowledge base and a lot of times if you
just use off-the-shelf model um
especially if you're not using a paid
service like open AI if you're just
using an off-the-shelf like hugging face
model they're not necessarily optimized
to actually uh encode your data set like
your specific data domain in the right
way and that's precisely where
potentially you might want to consider
fting right and the solution that we
propose here is generate a synthetic
query data set from raw text trunks
using LMS um and and use the synthetic
data set to actually fine tune antic mod
um this was proposed on a webinar um by
by Joe from besta and we were inspired
to actually add some of these
abstractions into L index itself um but
you know you can either have a human
label data set to find to your edting
model or you could have a synthetically
generated data set a synthetically
generated data set basically means that
you um take an llm um take in some input
document Corpus and then given this
input document generate the set of
questions from this document um and then
map these question answer pairs uh as a
training data set um to to your fine tun
algorithm the next piece is fine-tuning
llms um and and as we think about how do
you actually fine-tune llms and and what
can you fine-tune right to actually lead
you to to better performance for these
models um or for this overall system um
there's a few different
aspects um first is that the the weaker
llms um Can can potentially be bad this
is a type of at response synthesis
reasoning um structured outputs right so
if you're using stuff that's not gd4 if
you're using a llama 2 3.5 turbo they
might not be as good in terms of
generating a detailed answer uh
attending to the context within the
answer um actually out putting something
that's in a structured format like
Json um and so a solution here is you
can try to generate a synthetic data set
from raw text junk similar to before
right like use some some guide like
parent llm like a teacher LM like gd4 to
actually generate a set of uh candidate
questions and then also generate the
ground truth
answers and then given this as The
Guiding training data try to actually
fix all these issues like respons
reasoning structured outputs um by just
using this like kind of teacher data set
as a training data set for your weaker
model right so generate some sort of
data set whether it's to Output
structure of outputs output something
else using GPD form and then try to
actually uh teach like a student model
to to try to get better at at its job um
we have a variety of these abstractions
within LW index we have a full fine
tuning guide on both fineing llms as
well as embeddings as well as cross
encoders um and so we it's still in the
pretty basic exploratory stages but
there's definitely some benefits you can
get by trying to instruction tune these
Elms further um to better obey the task
at hand some other examples include
being able to handle custom instructions
like if you have prompts that you really
need the LMS to follow to adhere for
instance to a certain style or to
understand proprietary terminology
within your data set those are also
examples for fine tuning as
well here's just some basic resources
this basically wraps up the rest of talk
uh there's this the production um here's
a guide on just generally production rag
how do you build more advanced stuff
than just the basic
stuff um and in the last section which I
don't have time to get through here's
just some guides on building basically a
full stack application with llama Index
right um and this basically completes it
so that you basically have a functioning
full stack application uh Beyond just
all these techniques that I mentioned in
the in in the previous few slides um we
have a bunch of tools to help you get
started most all these are pretty much
free open source MIT license and so feel
free to clone as you want and if you're
building llms in Enterprise setting or
working with Gen rag systems we love to
chat um here's some basic QR code which
will link you to an office hours form
but thank
you cool um thanks a lot Jerry uh maybe
you have question for uh you have time
for one quick
question
um
for the uh for the person asking about
the presentations uh we will be uh
putting it in Discord under the uh talk
discussion this channel
hopefully cool sounds good do do I just
read do I read one the
questions uh I just put a the highest
voted question up on for you so how
would you process using rag problems of
splitting larger tables into chunks and
framework
recommendations great yeah that's a good
question question um I mean framework
recommendations we we have some of this
stuff with theml index so definitely
encourage you guys to to check it out um
I think it depends so for embedded
tables within an overall PDF document um
we actually have a bunch of tutorials
for this because um if the table's
embedded within a larger document it
tends to be pretty small um and so
there's no need to basically index it in
like a like a SQL database for instance
um and the way I think about processing
these tables is typically you get much
better performance by extracting like a
summary from it for instance using an LM
like captioning the table uh versus
embedding the table itself um and so for
instance given a table of Revenue you
probably want to embed the caption
Revenue right uh or table of revenues as
opposed to encoding all the revenue
numbers which will confuse your
embedding model and lead to bad
retrieval performance you can basically
use the same technique that I mentioned
in the slides the recursive retrieval
stuff like the small to big strategy
where you encode a reference to an
underlying trunk you can use that
similar strategy to basically process
embedded tables for generally Standalone
uh tables like just big structured data
sets uh which I guess I didn't really
touch on during the talk um there's text
a SQL right you you can basically just
like encode like put it in a structur
database and run some sort of structured
query language against so